en este vídeo hablaremos de cómo
encontrar la constante de velocidad que
para una reacción de primer orden veamos
este ejemplo en el que tenemos esta
tabla de datos
vamos a ver conocemos la concentración
del reactivo que es peróxido de
hidrógeno h2o2 a diferentes tiempos y
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 datos de concentración
y tiempo ok entonces la reacción general
que ocurre es la descomposición del
peróxido de hidrógeno para producir agua
h2o
y oxígeno esta reacción se lleva a cabo
a 40 grados celsius ahora la pregunta es
cuál es el valor de ca cuál es k
basándonos en los datos que tenemos de
concentración en el tiempo queremos
saber cuál es la constante de velocidad
k am hay dos formas en las que podemos
intentar responder esta pregunta una
forma que yo creo que es lo primero en
lo que piensan muchos es resolverlo
gráficamente entonces podríamos graficar
y como sabemos que esta es una reacción
de primer orden recordemos que para una
reacción de primer orden
hay que graficar el logaritmo natural de
la concentración en el tiempo contra el
tiempo
entonces si hacemos esto podemos usar la
ley de velocidad integrada para una
reacción de primer orden así podemos
decir que el logaritmo natural de la
concentración en cualquier tiempo es
igual a logaritmo natural de la
concentración inicial menos cate y así
podemos graficar nuestros datos entonces
primero hay que sacar el logaritmo
natural de esto y graficar lo contra el
tiempo
ya sabemos que la pendiente es igual a
menos que esta sería una muy buena forma
de resolver este problema pero yo les
voy a sugerir
sobre todo porque sabemos que esta es
una reacción de primer orden vamos a
resolverlo de una forma un poco
diferente vamos a ver qué es lo que hace
tan especiales a las reacciones de
primer orden bueno es que su tiempo de
vida media de un medio es una constante
pero además está relacionado con la
constante de velocidad que entonces la
vida media no cambia con el tiempo y
tenemos una ecuación
y medio es igual a logaritmo natural de
dos entre acá y si calculamos el
logaritmo natural de 2 nos queda 0.625
tenemos otro vídeo en el que hablamos
sobre cómo derivamos esta ecuación todo
lo que necesitamos es que sabemos que
por definición la vida media es el
tiempo que se necesita para pasar de la
concentración inicial a la mitad de la
concentración inicial entonces todo lo
que tenemos que hacer es sustituir un
medio por la concentración inicial y así
calcular t pero si estuviéramos en un
examen puede que sepamos esta ecuación o
que nos la den así que podemos usar esta
ecuación para calcular que sin tener que
graficar los datos esto es muy útil
sobre todo si no tienen una calculadora
gráfica dora en el examen entonces ahora
analicemos los datos y veamos si podemos
saber cuál es la vida media
aquí del primer dato al segundo voy a
enumerar los para que sea más fácil
cuando pasamos del dato 1 al 2 observen
que la concentración disminuyó a la
mitad y han pasado dos puntos 16 por 10
a la 4 segundos ok pero sólo para
asegurarnos de que el tiempo de vida
media es constante podemos analizar
algunos de los otros datos por ejemplo
si analizamos los datos 2 y 3
miren nuevamente la concentración
disminuyó a la mitad y de 3 a 4 ocurre
lo mismo de hecho para todos estos datos
si analizamos 2 la concentración siempre
disminuye a la mitad y siempre en un
tiempo de 2.16 por 10 a la 4 segundos
entonces ya sabemos que el tiempo de
vida media es igual a 2.16 por 10 a la 4
segundos y me gustaría mencionar que
este es un ejemplo ligeramente inventado
porque estos datos
muy bien si hiciéramos un experimento
con una reacción de primer orden y
medimos los datos existe una alta
probabilidad de que nuestros datos no
serán así de perfectos y eso está bien
de hecho es completamente normal no se
sientan mal si los datos que obtienen en
su experimento no son tan perfectos como
estos porque eso en realidad es una
buena señal pero bueno ahora que
conocemos el tiempo de vida media
analizando la tabla de datos ya podemos
reordenar esta ecuación para calcular
acá entonces acá es igual a cero punto
693 entre el tiempo de vida media y como
ya conocemos el tiempo de vida media
vamos a sustituirlo y calculamos que
entonces nos queda cero punto 693 entre
dos puntos 16 por 10 a la 4 segundos y
si usamos la calculadora nos queda que k
es igual a 3.21 x
a la menos 5 y nuestras unidades son 1 /
segundos así que lo más importante a
recordar es que para una reacción de
primer orden como tenemos un tiempo de
vida media constante podemos usar esta
ecuación tan práctica para calcular acá
si conocemos el tiempo de vida media o
viceversa si conocemos acá podemos
calcular la vida media y siempre será
fácil reconocer una reacción de primer
orden basándonos en la gráfica o en la
tabla de datos revisando que el tiempo
de vida media sea constante